[Music]
we need to make sure that children and
teens actually are part of the
conversation this is very new territory
even young children are impacted by this
and so there's quite a bit of work being
done to think about how do we talk to
children we know that from from the past
we know that for example after the
Boston Marathon bombing families that
actually talk to their children about
what was happening and about what was
being done those children did better
from a mental health perspective I've
been involved in response to oh goodness
9/11 Katrina earthquake in Sichuan China
scientists recognize that some events
happen and it's important to jump in
immediately to be able to understand it
mental health researchers have jumped in
to be able to see what can we be
learning now and continue to look at how
does this impact the future so prior to
the pandemic outbreak we had an ongoing
project that focused on the development
and social-emotional development health
and well-being of Chinese and Korean
American families with the start of the
probe in nineteen condemned and we
started to see reports of increased acts
of racism and phobia both on social
media and news and also some of that the
families were you know so reporting
having some of these experiences we're
doing the first phase of the unit
collection now and what we think is hope
is the height of the pandemic and then
in about six to seven months we'll
hoping that you know things will have
improved and we'll be able to follow up
then what happens with regard to their
mental health and experiences
discrimination and anxieties and fears
and whether the toes and it dips down or
whether there is some you know sir
post-traumatic types similar types of
effects what are our resources that
families have that communities have that
parents and children have that we can
draw on they're going to be looking to
the trusted adults in their lives you as
an adult
are probably the most important figure
in terms of how children and teens hold
cope in something like a pandemic one of
the things that is so important for
children is having a scheduler routine
well that has gone by the wayside as
much as parents can begin to put back
some kind of routine if I know I still
have to get up I still need to sign in
to my French class I still need to do
homework that regular routine helps we
would like to tell parents to make sure
that they are also not transmitting
their fears and anxieties to their
children indirectly in ways that they
might might not be thinking about making
sure to be supportive and validating
children's concerns and fears before
trying to come in and you know trying to
fix it for them for those who just
arrived you are chatting me your answer
privately in situations where children
are having difficulties at home having a
teacher who is a positive relationship
conveys kind of a protective factor to
an otherwise challenging situation at
the end of 2019 beginning of 2020 we
started a longitudinal study to track
the mental health and emotional and
behavioral outcomes in 235 children
enrolled in after-school programs in
Toronto Canada following the
announcement of the pandemic we have
seen a bit of a pattern in the data
where children are perhaps exhibiting
slightly higher levels of emotional
behavioral difficulties
these tend to be outcomes and patterns
that are driven by children and families
who are more susceptible to the
influences of the social determinants of
health people of lower income people who
are generally marginalized so the
families who are going to be least
impacted on the months who have
computers in our home who have access to
other resources who have access to space
where they can get their energies out
we're leaving out and full you know a
large proportion of our children who
don't have these privileges these
luxuries we know from all the disaster
research once we can stand schools back
up children do better it's been amazing
to see and hear about a lot of these
educators who are phoning home who are
checking in we're brainstorming
solutions who are coming up with ways of
doing home school this is a time when we
need to work together I think that we
share really the responsibility for good
Public Health practice but also good
practices related to you know embracing
and really valuing diversity from 9/11
we began to recognize that children can
be impacted in so many different ways
but 9/11 also showed us that it doesn't
matter whether you're right in New York
or whether you're in Missoula Montana
that event still impacted you I think
everybody will be able to talk with
their children or grandchildren or
nieces and nephews and others down the
road about where I was and what I did
during Kovan nineteen
[Music]
[Applause]